el caso recuerda a la redada que se
realizó en la casa de Donald Trump y
donde se hallaron documentos
clasificados Pero qué tan pertinente es
comparar estos dos casos tienen el mismo
nivel de gravedad
son graves uno puedes criticar a Trump
por tener documentos y no tener la mente
abierta para ver qué ha pasado que ahora
resultan que hay documentos también en
las oficinas de biden Sin embargo lo más
serio En mi opinión que hizo Trump fue
negarse entregar esa documentación
cuando fue descubierta que estaba allí
por el por los archivos nacionales y
mentirles firmar que los abogados del
firmaron documentos falsos diciendo que
se había entregado toda la documentación
en el caso de biden se encuentran estos
documentos y inmediatamente él le pide a
sus abogados que lo entreguen a los
archivos nacionales Así que para mí lo
lo más serio de todo esto es que tal
parecía que el fiscal general estaba a
punto de presentar un encauzamiento en
contra de Trump por los hechos
y ahora ese fiscal tiene que balancear y
ver si esta investigación puede proceder
sabiendo que el presidente biden puede
estar sujeto a unas investigación
similar de eso precisamente quiero que
hablemos podría biden enfrentar cargos
relacionados con Este descubrimiento qué
repercusiones podría haber contra el
mandatario
el el llevarte documentos
intencionalmente es es un delito aquí la
pregunta es si esto fue algo que se hizo
intencional o no Trump repito el hecho
de que aguantó esos documentos y se negó
a entregarlos por más de un año eso
demuestra intención personal de quedarse
con los documentos robados en el caso de
biden si se descubre que esto
simplemente fue un descuido que esos
documentos estuvieron puestos en esas
cajas por empleados de la casa de la
casa de vicepresidencial cuando él se
fue de su vicepresidencia y que no tuvo
intención personal pues no no hubiera
delito en ese caso Estamos a una estamos
simplemente comenzando un proceso en el
caso de biden y estábamos ya terminando
un proceso de investigación en el caso
del Trump es algo increíble que la
coincidencia de estos dos hechos salga a
relucir y lo y la parte la forma más
En mi opinión es que estos documentos se
descubrieron en noviembre y ahora es que
se le da publicidad a lo que sucedió
señor peñalver sin duda los republicanos
han aprovechado este tema para
cuestionar el comportamiento de biden
ahora que controlan la cámara de
representantes Qué medidas podríamos
estar viendo teniendo en cuenta que por
ejemplo ya han reunido esfuerzos para
poner bajo escrutinio a las
investigaciones que se han realizado
desde la administración de biden no
Prepárate para muchas investigaciones
relacionadas con baile y con su hijo
Hunter biden las cuestiones de Cómo fue
que se acumuló el el dinero que ganó
millones de dólares que ganó Durante los
últimos años de la vicepresidencia de su
padre si se logra establecer algún
vínculo directo de que se utilizó la
influencia del vicepresidente En aquel
momento para poner a su hijo en la junta
de directores de la empresa barisma en
en Ucrania que que capacidad tenía
Hunter biden Sentado en una mesa de
directores en una de una empresa
petrolera y ganando un dineral todos
estos son temas válidos para investigar
lo que yo creo que el pueblo americano
Está también cansado de estas
investigaciones partidistas con todos
los problemas que enfrenta el país Así
que el partido republicano tiene que
tiene que ver No arriesgarse a lanzar
investigaciones personales y olvidándo
los temas reales para los que fueron
electos y se le dio la mayoría a los
republicanos en el congreso